the idea that work might be fulfilling
rather than just painfully necessary is
a strikingly recent invention open dr.
Johnson's celebrated dictionary
published in 1755 and the word
fulfillment doesn't even appear nowadays
in a prosperous world we don't only
expect to obtain money through our labor
we also to a greater or lesser extent
expect to find meaning and satisfaction
it's a big ask and helps to explain why
so many of us have career crises often
on a Sunday evening as the Sun begins to
set to help us on the quest for
fulfilling work here are six useful
ideas firstly accept that being confused
about careers is perfectly normal in the
pre-industrial world there were at most
some 2,000 different trades out there
nowadays there are estimated to be half
a million different options the result
we can become so anxious about making
the wrong choice we end up making no
choice at all psychologists call this
the paradox of choice paralysis stemming
from too many options we should
acknowledge that confusion is natural
and fear entirely normal but let neither
of these scupper our chances forever
secondly know yourself
it's the oldest philosophical
recommendation and its particular
relevance to careers for 99% of us
knowing what we want to do doesn't arise
spontaneously like for example knowing
what to eat most of us don't have a
calling we don't hear a commanding
godlike voice directing us to
accountancy or packaging and
distribution that isn't to say we don't
have tastes or inclinations we just
don't know them clearly enough which is
a perilous position to be in as not
having a plan quickly puts us at the
mercy of those who do have one we only
catch glimpses little hints of our
tastes so what we have to do is learn to
pick up on their faint sounds start by
parking any concerns for money for a
time financial panic too often kills all
dialog with a more authentic passionate
sides of one's nature write down without
being too logical or analytical about it
everything you've ever enjoyed doing or
making which might include building a
tree house or sorting out the winter
clothes the weirder and more offbeat the
lists the better in the long and
confused tangle that follows there will
somewhere be the shape of an ideal
future
working self but it'll be very messed up
and in need of being analyzed thoroughly
that's where philosophy comes in
philosophy is the art of clearing up and
demanding logic of our first thoughts
thirdly think a lot if it might take a
couple of days even a week to choose a
new car it could fairly take a year or
more of sustained daily reflection to
start to identify a career that fits we
tend to feel guilty about this imagining
we're being self indulgent far from it
we may need to empty every weekend for
months just sort out the biggest
conundrum of our lives to make sure we
don't continue to spend the rest of our
lives trapped in a job unwittingly
chosen for us by our unknowing 16-year
old selves we need to be properly
generous about the amount of time we'll
need to give this fourthly try something
it's tempting to imagine we'll be able
to work out the shape of the workplace
and of our own characters simply through
a pure process of reflection but we need
data and we can only understand
ourselves and others by colliding with
the real world in the process getting to
know both it and our own natures we used
to take small non irrevocable steps to
gather information for example by
shadowing interning or volunteering we
mustn't think we always have to resign
on Monday we can investigate our futures
through branching projects on the side
of existing jobs 5 reflect on what makes
people unhappy every successful business
is at heart an attempt to solve someone
else's problem the bigger and more
urgent the problem the greater the
opportunity to flex your entrepreneurial
muscles consider an average day and
everything in it that might make someone
unhappy from losing the house keys to
finding the food a little greasy -
arguing yet again with their spouse each
of these is a business opportunity
waiting to be exploited it's a chance
for us to serve which is what work
really is it's easy to imagine that
everything's been done and tried
nonsense were unhappy enough for
capitalism to have many more centuries
of invention and creativity to it 6 be
confident so many bad self-help books
are about confidence it can be tempting
to dismiss the whole topic as nonsense
but in a peculiar and rather humbling
way it truly does seem as if the
difference between success and failure
is sometimes nothing less than the
courage to give it a go the
- imagine oneself into a role to surmise
one doesn't need to ask anyone for
permission that many of the top
positions simply belonged to those who
dare to boldly ask for them a lack of
confidence is at heart a
misunderstanding of the way the world
works
it's an internalized feudalism which
imagines that only certain people but
not oneself have the right preordained
to get certain things it isn't true
as we know a lot more is possible that
we might think at our moments of
timidity and doubt that's the start of
the path towards a job we won't regret
and our deathbeds
which should always be the ultimate
criterion
you